[Music]
shift your weight
and turn around that point here
shake it away and bring it around
boom shift and then
take time
[Music]
okay let's see so you get cut the zodia
is not for me to crank down on this
thing shut him down
aikido is a jiu jitsu it is
non-contestation
okay so i is he he's pushing right
that's why i'm turning if he's pulling
then it's hitting me
so as he pushed his first yield goes
here
and then i turn and out his balance
falls that way so he moves that way
and i have to wait for him to move that
way so i'm over here and
he's going to step there because try to
leave try to leave your foot there
right and you see what's happening so he
he steps there so i'd let him step there
and now this tells me this is where you
can move as long as you're not pushing
or pulling on that elbow
so that is where i can move
boom then don't crank don't hear
don't look for slack this tells you
where you can move
to me this is different
[Music]
so
okay so the yield oh and then in
[Music]
yield
keep it on your center line up it goes
face
[Music]
all right
inside the grip